Epictetus the stoic philosopher is among
my all-time favorites and this month
December 2017 we have three great online
events where you can learn more about
epictetus and his philosophy in
particular on the topics that we're
going to be discussing choice and
character I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a minute but first I want
to give you the dates so you can put put
them on your calendar on Monday December
11th at 11 a.m. in Central Standard Time
we will be having the free 45 minute
webinar that's open to anybody who wants
to join then following that up later in
the week on Saturday December 16th at 10
o'clock in the morning Central Time and
4 o'clock in the afternoon we're gonna
be having these these much more
intensive two-hour long seminars there
are limited seats for those and there is
a small tuition so you may want to do
hold off on that and check out the
webinar first or you might want to sign
up right away just to make sure that you
get a seat because I think these are
going to be very popular offerings given
how how widespread the interest is in
modern stoicism and how important
epictetus is to that so the 45 minute
long webinar anybody can join I
encourage everybody to participate we
have about 25 minutes of discussion
presentation of the topics and then it's
it's 20 minutes of open Q&A and
discussion when it comes to the two-hour
long intensive seminars in in those we
actually break it up so that there are
opportunities for some Q&A and the last
30 minutes of the entire online seminar
is devoted to discussion and question
and answer on the topic but there's a
lot of material being presented I think
it would be useful to have read at least
the enchiridion beforehand but you don't
absolutely have to I will be presenting
epictetus as thought making it clear to
everybody so we've got some really
exciting events
coming up I think this is stuff that's
very practical as well as interesting
from a theoretical perspective we're
finishing the year really strong after
going through an entire sequence of free
webinars and then online seminars month
after month after month I'm very happy
to be doing this on Epictetus coming
back to him after doing it a little bit
earlier in the year so you can tell just
by looking at my book just how much I'm
actually referencing
Epictetus and his discourses so hope you
can join us and again I can't impress
upon you how excited I am to be teaching
this material if you're interested in
understanding these matters go ahead and
join us